first on cbs this morning mickey guyton
joins us from her home in los angeles
mickey thanks so much for being with us
good morning welcome
good morning how are you i'm doing
really well you wrote this song
actually uh a year ago and when you were
going through a painful period
and but you put it out very suddenly on
instagram without any fanfare at all
what made you suddenly want to release
it
well the pandemic has been just so hard
on all of us and during that time we saw
ahmad arbory and brianna taylor
and george floyd all in like a
couple months span get murdered in such
an unjust way
and i had this song that was expressing
so much of what i was feeling and i felt
a lot of other people were feeling so i
just
put it on my instagram just to for
healing purposes and then spotify asks
for it and then
here we are it's been a crazy response
what kind of what sort of reaction did
you get
well i put it out you know about two
weeks ago and
i still have not been able to get to all
of my messages
on instagram and i've never had that
kind of response to a song
before and it's just been so beautiful
it really has
mickey you nashville
has not been particularly welcoming
nashville i'm sorry country radio i
wanted to say
has not been particularly well welcoming
to women on the airwaves
it's not easy if you're a woman getting
on the air i can't imagine how difficult
it is if you're a black woman trying to
get on the air
and you've said that i did nashville the
nashville way for so long with very
little result
this is a pretty brave thing to do to
put out this song
yes um yeah i
[Music]
for so long i was living somebody else's
truth and i wasn't living
my truth and this song is an example of
that
you know country music is three chords
in the truth
and people pride and have so much pride
in country music because it's honest
music but i wasn't being honest
and this is the first real time that
i've been honest with my words and my
lyrics and my message
and it's so freeing
it's so freeing and i don't care what
way i'm supposed to go i know this is
the right way because it's who i am
you were going through a period of pain
when you wrote this what was happening
yes well i i was doing the nashville
way the nashville way and there are so
many
i was seeing so many artists come out
with songs with trap beats in their
their songs and flat build hats and
timberlands and calling it country
and if i tried to just put out any kind
of song it was overly scrutinized and it
was really difficult for me
to navigate that it was really really
hard and i
felt trapped within myself and part of
that was my doing because i could have
easily said
enough is enough but i didn't and
finally when i wrote that song when i
wrote black like me that was
kind of one of the first moments that i
was freeing myself of these
unnecessary chains that i'd put on
myself from the expectations of the
industry
mickey i've been listening to you as you
know since 2015 you are still on my
playlist
i'm so excited that you've got new music
coming out bravo bravo to you
i want to follow up on something anthony
said you know when he said it's very
brave of you
to release the lyrics because they are
so personal and they are
clearly very painful to you were you
nervous about the reaction that you
could receive
yeah from the country music world abs
absolutely i was nervous there were even
possible talks about me getting security
just in case
i started getting threats from people
and that was scary for me when i put the
song out you know we're all stuck in our
homes
and i stayed in my bed the entire day
because i was
i was nervous i didn't want to let
anybody down i didn't know what the
response was going to be and was
actually the exact opposite it was so
positive and loving it was like people
were waiting for that for me
let me just say for people it's
beautiful it is beautiful i love your
voice you are described as this take
leanne rhymes top 40 sensibilities
patsy klein's gift for heart tugging
balladry and whitney houston's massive
pipes
and you might just capture the magic of
this texas
powerhouse they're talking about you
what do we need to do what do you think
needs to be done to make country that's
what i say wow but it's true mickey
guyton
what do you think needs to be done in
country music to make it more inclusive
what do you think it's 20 20. well first
first of all there needs to it is 20 20
and
if you look at the charts right now
there are still not enough
women on the charts and if there are
women on the charts they're getting
played at night
and i have first hand seen the
discrimination that is happening
against white women in the industry and
as a black woman who knows firsthand
what discrimination
feels like i can't sit here
and not say anything and they're like
we're always told why we will fail but
we're never told why we will succeed
and this industry really from the top
down
whether you're in the radio world
whether you're at a record company
whether you're at a publishing company
these companies need to actively truly
give
women and people of color opportunities
we don't want handouts
but we want opportunities and equal
opportunities totally fair mickey guyton
it's a beautiful record thanks for being
with us this morning congratulations